let's go to the phone lines the phone
lines are hopping today see what's on
folks minds
the number is of course 617-830-4750
let's start with our caller from the 828
area code caller from 828 what's your
name where you calling from
yes hello this is patrick i'm calling
from
near asheville north carolina what can i
do for you patrick
i had a sort of proposal for you to
encourage accelerationists or
revolutionary leftists to vote for joe
biden
okay i would propose that
joe biden is actually their acceleration
as candidate
of the two candidates that are available
or or joe biden is
actually an accelerationist candidate
of the two that are available okay
because
um if you're familiar with the the
j-curve theory of revolution
that revolutions happen when
expectations don't meet reality
so if trump gets elected everyone will
expect things to get worse
and become more authoritarian yes joe
biden gets elected people will expect
things to get better but i would say
they won't get that much better and that
might be more likely to cause a
revolution than if trump gets elected
that's very interesting so to say it
another way patrick
the idea is if trump wins
and people expect the world to get worse
and it does um expectations and reality
will be aligned
and often that will not cause dramatic
change
on the other hand if people vote for joe
biden
and other other than the
accelerationists i guess a lot of people
believe things will get better if joe
biden is elected they might not be great
but they'd be better
if it then doesn't happen it might
actually catalyze a demand for more
significant change is the idea
yeah that's right it's interesting i
mean i don't know
listen i don't know that i believe it so
what you're basically saying is
would this be a way to convince
the sort of never biden people to vote
for biden the revolutionary left to vote
for biden
but it's something i don't actually
believe will happen i don't know if it's
honest to use trickery but it's
certainly an interesting idea
it's more of a possibility i mean if
you're looking at odds
odds are better for joe biden in that
either he makes things a lot better
and that's good things get a lot better
or they only get a tiny bit better
which could also be good if you're an
accelerationist and that
change will happen more likely it's an
interesting idea i mean i'll propose it
if i get one of these revolutionary
leftists calling in i'll certainly
propose it to them and see what they say
okay thank you and i had one other quick
question sure
um when you're speaking in spanish would
you pronounce your name
david or david well in spanish it's
david yeah
um i would just say when aoc becomes
president you might need to explain
what code is
sorry i might need to you're breaking up
patrick i might need to explain what
when aoc
is president code switching
code switching okay well yeah that's
that's something to think about
uh patrick thank you for the call very
much appreciate it